ce matin à champigny-sur-vude on
s'activait pour effacer les traces de la
crue du mâble ce petit cours d'eau
rejoignait aujourd'hui progressivement
son lit mais hier cette ruelles étaient
entièrement sous les eaux comme
d'ailleurs plusieurs rues de la commune
dont l'accentrale
vous aviez beaucoup de choses là
heureusement ce sont que des dépendances
si cet habitant a eu de la chance ce
n'est pas le cas de la bibliothèque
municipale voisine située à deux pas
dumasble hier à 18h plusieurs dizaines
de centimètres d'eau le bilan
aujourd'hui est lourd pas 900 livres des
meubles je pense que les tout la
formatic est fichu voilà les ordinateurs
étaient à la hauteur de l'eau
conséquence des pluies diluviennes de
mardi et mercredi où l'on a compté
jusqu'à 40 mm d'eau en une heure le
meble est sorti de son lit vers midi
hier jeudi inondant les rues du
centre-ville et s'invitant dans les
propriétés des particuliers 70 pompiers
ont été mobilisés rien qu'hier ils sont
intervenus une centaine de fois
Champigny et à Richelieu et depuis ce
matin retour au calme mais beaucoup
d'opérations de pompage des eaux dans
les caves notamment sensuelle
actuellement c'est de l'assèchement
et donc là ça s'est passé quand
ce midi le sous-préfet de Chinon c'est
notamment rendu à la caserne des
pompiers de Richelieu centre de contrôle
des opérations toutes les routes ont été
rendues pratiquables mais les dégâts
sont importants réinca Champigny 60
foyers ont été touchés par la crue ou
par des coulées debout plusieurs
commerces ont été impactés le toit de la
maternelle a subi des dégâts suite à des
infiltrations d'eau et surtout une
maison du centre-ville menace maintenant
de s'écrouler des gravats qui se sont
gorgés d'eau qui poussent sur les murs
et ça risque de couper la seule voie qui
traverse le village la préfecture n'a
pas donné l'autorisation mère pour
détruire cette propriété privée
quasiment à l'abandon ventre de prendre
cet arrêté de périlyminant il faut bien
entendu qu'il s'assure que on soit bien
dans la situation de péril imminence ça
prend certes du temps mais en attendant
on va sécuriser avec les forces de
l'ordre pour éviter que il y ait tout
risque
en tout cas d'effondrement sur des
personnes quant à l'arrêter de
catastrophes naturelles les demandes
seront rapidement transmises au
ministère de l'Intérieur